THE PRESIDENT HUDDLES WITH HIS
CABINET NEXT HOUR.
HE DOES SO FACING WHAT YOU MIGHT
CALL A HIGH WIRE CHALLENGE.
TO NAVIGATE A STILL TO-DO LIST
WHILE TRYING TO DEFY MIDTERM
ELECTION HISTORY.
NINE WEEKS EXACTLY UNTIL WE
COUNT YOUR VOTES, AND THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING
REMAINS IN PERILOUS TERRITORY.
BUT IT IS ON AN UPWARD
TRAJECTORY, AND EVERY TICK UP
IMPROVES DEMOCRATS' ODDS.
TODAY, A CABINET MEET TO GO
PROMOTE PROGRESS MADE OVER THE
SUMMER.
THE BIDEN BET, THAT SHOWING YOUR
GOVERNMENT AT WORK CAN HELP ARE
E FRAME THE MIDTERMS AS A CHOICE
BETWEEN NORMAL AND CRAZY.
>> THIS IS NOT YOUR FATHER'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THIS IS A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
PARTY, MAN.
THESE GUYS ARE DIFFERENT.
I'VE WORKED WITH A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS, CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS I WORK WITH, GOT A
LOT DONE, BUT IT WAS ALWAYS --
THERE WAS ALWAYS SOMETHING
DECENT ABOUT THE WORK.
THIS NEW GROUP HEADED BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, THE FORMER
DEFEATED PRESIDENT, WE FOUND
OURSELVES IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE ARE EITHER GOING TO LOOK
FORWARD OR LOOK BACKWARDS, AND
IT'S CLEAR WHICH WAY HE WANTS TO
LOOK, IT'S CLEAR WHICH WAY THE
NEW MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE.
THEY'RE EXTREME.
>> WITH ME TO SHARE THEIR
REPORTINGS AND INSIGHTS, SO, THE
PRESIDENT SITS DOWN WITH HIS
CABINET NEXT HOUR.
HE WANTS TO SAY WE'RE DOING
THINGS RELEVANT TO YOUR LIVES,
THEREFORE, DEFY HISTORY.
SAW THE PRESIDENT ON THE TRAIL
YESTERDAY, HOW DO THEY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE SEE HIS ROLE IN
THESE CRITICAL FINAL NINE WEEKS?
>> WELL, THEY WANT HIM TO BE OUT
THERE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE, SO I
THINK WE CAN EXPECT TO SEE --
JUST IN THE PAST WEEK, WE SAW
HIM OUT AND ABOUT THREE TIMES ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, AND WE CAN
EXPECT THAT TO CONTINUE.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTS TO SEE HIM
OUT ON THE ROAD EVEN IF THERE
ARE SOME DEMOCRATS WHO DON'T
WANT TO BE SEEN NEXT TO THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE IF IT ISN'T
THE PRESIDENT, WHO ELSE IS GOING
TO PUSH A LOT OF THE BIG
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THEY HAD DONE,
INFRASTRUCTURE, PRESCRIPTION
DRUG REFORM, AND ALL THESE OTHER
ELEMENTS AS WELL AS THE FACT
THAT NOW THE PRESIDENT IS
STARTING TO INSERT HIMSELF AND
SPEAK VERY DIRECTLY ABOUT WHAT
HE SEES AS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT HE SEES AS
DRIFING IT WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> SO TEAM BIDEN AND SOME OF THE
DEMO
DEMOCRATS THINK THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE OUT THERE MORE OFTEN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF AN ELECTION, NATHAN,
REPUBLICANS STILL HAVE AN EDGE
ON THE ECONOMY, REPUBLICANS HAVE
A GIANT EDGE ON CRIME.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
EDGE ON INFLATION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS WHO
THINK THE PRESIDENT IS IN
CHARGE.
YOU SAY IT'S NOT HIS FAULT.
BUT HE'S IN CHARGE.
THAT'S THE WAY IT NORMALLY
WORKS.
WHO THINK JOE BIDEN SHOULD STAY
OUT OF THE WAY, DO DEMOCRATS
INSTEAD FOCUS ON THIS, ABORTION.
>> ANY DEMOCRAT THAT'S ON THE
BALLOT WANTS BIDEN'S NUMBERS TO
IMPROVE FOR THIS FALL, BUT THEY
ALSO DON'T WANT AN ELECTION
BASED ON DO YOU THINK JOE BIDEN
IS DOING A GOOD JOB OR NOT
BECAUSE STILL A MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS DISAPPROVE OF THE JOB
HE'S DOING.
THERE'S THAT BALANCE OF GET HIM
OUT THERE, PROMOTE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, BUT KEEP THE
FOCUS ON REPUBLICANS BECAUSE THE
MORE THE VOTERS ARE FOCUSED ON
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP OR WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING, THAT IS
WHERE DEMOCRATS BENEFIT BECAUSE
VOTERS ARE PRIMED FOR CHANGE,
BUT IF THEY SEE REPUBLICANS AS
TOO EXTREME AS AN ALTERNATIVE,
THEY MIGHT STICK WITH THE STATUS
QUO.
>> TRUMP'S REEMERGENCE HAS GIVEN
BIDEN A WINDOW TO GET BACK INTO
THE RACE WITH A DIFFERENTMENT
PACT.
WHEN HE'S CENTER STAGE WITH THE
MICROPHONE, HE'S SAYING THIS
ELECTION IS A CHOICE BETWEEN THE
DIRECTION WE'RE MOVING IN AND
GOING BACK TO THE MONTHS AFTER
2020.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S GOING TO
WORK.
ABORTION IS PROBABLY A CLEARER
POLITICAL BET IN SOME STATES,
BUT THAT PLUS HIS POLL NUMBERS
INCHING UP HAS MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR HIM TO GET BACK OUT THERE.
>> AND YOU SEE A SLIGHT
EVOLUTION IN HOW HE'S TALKING
ABOUT THAT WHEN HE IS OUT THERE.
HE THE FUND RAISER WHERE HE
TALKED ABOUT SEMIFASCISM.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT MAGA EXTREME
ELEMENTS, AND YESTERDAY, LISTEN
TO THIS.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE MODERATED.
>> NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN IS A
MAGA REPUBLICAN.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN EMBRACES
THAT EXTREME IDEOLOGY.
I KNOW BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK WITH MAIN STREAM
REPUBLICANS MY WHOLE CAREER.
BUT THE EXTREME MAGA REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS HAVE CHOSEN TO GO
BACKWARDS FULL OF ANGER, HATE,
VIOLENCE, AND DIVISION.
BUT TOGETHER, WE CAN AND WE MUST
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT PATH,
FORWARD.
>> THE IN CONGRESS PART WAS
SIGNIFICANT THERE, NUMBER ONE,
BECAUSE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE
TRYING TO SAY HE'S SMEARING THE
VOTERS OUT THERE.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN IS A MAGA
REPUBLICAN.
THAT SEEMS A LITTLE MORE NUANCED
IN THE IDEA THAT IF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO DEFY THE
ODDS AND ESPECIALLY WIN THESE
SENATE RACES AND PENNSYLVANIA
AND WISCONSIN, OHIO, THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED SOME REPUBLICAN
VOTES TO DO IT.
>> EXACTLY.
YOU HAVE BIDEN TRYING TO DEFINE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN A WAY
THAT BENEFITS HIM.
I CAN'T WORK WITH THE MAGA
FOLKS, BUT I CAN STILL WORK WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE.
HE STILL WANTS TO BE THAT GUY
THAT CAN SWAY MODERATE
REPUBLICAN VOTERS, AND IF YOU'RE
CALLING THE MAGA VOTERS, IT
DOESN'T WORK.
>> AND IT TOOK HIM TIME TO
ACTUALLY GO AFTER WHAT HE'S
CALLING MAGA REPUBLICANS.
AND I WAS TALKING TO THE SENATOR
OF HAWAII AND HE SAYS BIDEN HAS
LONG WORKED WITH THESE
REPUBLICANS AND STILL CONSIDERS
SOME OF THEM FRIENDS SO IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR HAD HIM TO
CHARACTERIZE THEM IN THIS WAY.
BUT HE'S NOT THE FIRST PRESIDENT
TO WARN OF DOMESTIC THREATS
INTERNALLY.
>> WHAT'S THE BEST ROLE IN THE
FINAL NINE WEEKS IN THE SENSE
THAT IF YOU LISTENED TO
YESTERDAY, YOU HEARD THAT, AND
THE PRESIDENT ALSO TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF HIS ACHIEVEMENTS.
BIDEN SAYS, BIG WIN FOR YOU ON
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
>> WE BEAT PHARMA THIS YEAR!
WE BEAT FARM MA THIS YEAR, AND
IT MATTERED.
WE'RE GOING THE CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
WE FINALLY BEAT PHARMA.
>> SO AT THE CABINET MEETING,
HE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT.
HE'LL TALK ABOUT OTHER THINGS
THEY DID IN THE REAR VIEW
MIRROR.
WHAT ABOUT THE LAST NINE WEEKS?
WHAT DOES HE WANT TO ACHIEVE,
INCLUDING ON THE TABLE IS THE
IDEA THEY WILL TRY MAYBE
ATTACHING IT TO THE RESOLUTION
OF KEEPING THE GOVERNMENT OPEN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE CODIFICATION OF SAME SEX
MARRIAGE, THE RETURN OF THIS
PROMISE TO CAP INSULIN PRICES,
THERE ARE FEW ITEMS LIKE THIS
THAT THERE'S AN ANTITRUST BILL
THAT BIG TECH HAS BEEN FIGHTING
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO GET CREDIT
FOR BRINGING TO A VOTE AT LEAST.
TO SOME EXTENT WHETHER THEY GET
THESE THINGS OR NOT AS MUCH AS
THEIR ABILITY TO SAY, WE TRIED.
BUT THEY COULD, AND THAT WOULD
BE THE ICING ON THE CAKE AS WHAT
THEY SEE AS MOVING IN A VERY
GOOD DIRECTION.
WILL IT BE ENOUGH TO HOLD THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES?
HISTORY SAYS NO.
BUT IT WASN'T EVEN A POSSIBILITY
A FEW WEEKS AGO.
SOME OF THIS MAY BE PERSONAL IF
BIDEN WAS WATCHING ANY OF
TRUMP'S RALLY OVER THE WEEKEND,
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUE JONATHAN
SWAN WAS THERE.
FOR TV, FOR FAMILY SAFE
ENVIRONMENT, PRETTY RAUNCHY SET
OF MESSAGING INSIDE THOSE
RALLIES ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU REALLY WOULD SEE A DIFFERENT
MESSAGE, THAT IS PERSONAL, IT'S
VENDETTA-BASED, IT'S ABOUT
GRIEVANCE.
BIDEN HAS TRIED IT ON SOME OF
THESE SOCIAL AND POLICY ISSUES
TRYING TO SHOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
AT LEAST INCHING THE BALL
FORWARD.
>> AGAIN, THERE WILL BE A DEBATE
ABOUT HOW MUCH THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE OUT THERE AND BE
VISIBLE, BUT THE REEMERGENCE OF
TRUMP IN THE SENSE THAT IF WE
WENT BACK A FEW MONTHS, THE IDEA
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE WAY UNDER THE
WATER ON CRIME COMPARED TO
REPUBLICANS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAD THIS
ADVANTAGE ON INFLATION.
THIS HAD H A TRADITIONAL SUBURB
REACTION.
THE SUBURBS WHICH MADE GEORGE W.
PRESIDENT, TRUMP REEMERGES,
ALONG WITH THE ABORTION ISSUE,
AND WE SEE THE SWINGS BACK IN
THE SUBURBS AGAIN.
IN SENATE RACES OR RACES FOR
GOVERN NORSE, THEY ARE DECIDED
IN THE SUBURBS.
RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS A
REPUBLICAN ADVANTAGE SEEMS TO BE
DRIFTING AWAY.
>> RIGHT.
WE SEE VOTERS CONFLICTED BETWEEN
THE ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT WITH A
THREAT OF WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF
REPUBLICANS ARE IN CHARGE OR IF
DEMOCRATS REMAIN IN CHARGE.
WHAT I THINK IS INTERESTING
ABOUT WHAT BIDEN IS DOING NOW
AND REMEMBERING BACK TO 2010
WHERE THERE WAS CRITICISM THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA AFTER THEY
PASSED THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT,
HE WAS NOT OUT TRYING TO SELL
IT, AND HE HUNG DEMOCRATS OUT TO
DRY, BUT THIS TIME, AT LEAST
BIDEN IS OUT THERE TRYING TO
SELL THE AGENDA, AND IT'S A
MARKED DIFFERENCE.
WE'LL SEE IF IT'S ENOUGH.